well hey you guys it's a movie
retrospective and I had actually been
wanting to re-watch this movie for a
little while because I could had kind of
like I think I had low-key forgotten
that this was a John Carpenter movie
um and it's one of those kind of movies
where
I mean it's not like his best work I
feel like it's not bad though but it's
better than like some of the other
movies that he did in the 1990s you know
what I mean like I think it's better
than John Carpenter's vampires or what
was that other one Ghost of Mars yeah
like I don't think he actually made
those movies well I mean this one you I
will say that you can tell that this is
a movie that and he will admit this as
well but he's like well this isn't it
wasn't like a passion project of his it
was basically just like a contractual
obligation but he was kind of excited
about doing it because like I said I
think that they asked him because you
know he had remade
the thing like the thing from another
world like from the 1950s and when they
were looking to do a remake of the 1960
film Village of the Damned which was
actually based on an older novel then
they figured oh we'll call him up
because he did such a good job with the
thing which I did like the thing when it
came out like in the early 1980s you
know wasn't a big hit or anything but by
the time the 90s had rolled around I'm
pretty sure everybody was on the board
on board with the fact that it was a
classic so he was the guy that you
called and I think the idea initially
for wanting to redo the movie was mainly
stemmed from you know them remaking uh
Invasion of the Body Snatchers like in
1978 and that being really successful so
they were kind of like mining all of
these films from the old days uh to kind
of like make them and like expose them
to like to a new audience I guess I
remember when this came out my friends
were going to see it and they came back
and they were like yeah it's pretty good
it's pretty good they weren't real
enthused about it it was it was a mixed
response I guess they
I don't know
yeah it wasn't really
it was a good movie it was okay it's
just that it wasn't like over the top
special effects it wasn't uh it wasn't
anything real new it
I think it kind of came off as stale to
the audience back in those days but it's
not bad it's good yeah it's a weird
flick it kind of reminds me a little bit
of The Andromeda Strain meets [ __ ]
Invasion of the Body Snatchers so it's
kind of like that it has a little bit of
as far as kind of like pacing and stuff
goes and you know it's kind of the
cinematography the way it looks it kind
of reminds me of a little bit of the fog
because they shot it I think in the same
place I think basically John Carpenter
one of the reasons he wanted to do this
too was that he shot it like pretty much
in his hometown like where he was living
at the time which was I don't remember
where it was like somewhere in
California like Northern California I
think and he's like so I thought it was
cool that we could shoot it like right
around my house so I could like go home
at night and stuff like that so there
you can see like a lot of the a lot of
the shots of like the Landscapes and
stuff like that are like really really
nice I think what blew the movie was the
alien in the jar
yeah I think that's what blew the movie
you eventually see kind of like the
reveal there's an alien in a jar that
they have and it just obviously a doll
it's obviously a little baby doll or
something tricked up it's just
nah that wasn't good enough it was that
and well the crazy thing about this is
that nicotero worked on this Greg
nicotero like knb and some of the
special effects and we'll get into likes
because some a lot of them were cut out
but like some of the special effects in
there and I'm thinking this isn't like a
real gory or graphic movie but the one
shot like where the lady Burns to death
at the end like that looks great that
looks like really [ __ ] up and gross
and everything like that but
um it's I don't know if they built that
alien because yeah it almost looks like
a stock
thing that you'd buy at like a Halloween
store yeah it looked like a couch for
like 25 times it looked like a Cabbage
Patch doll they dressed up or something
like that garbage pail kid
the alien cabbage yeah and this was this
this was in a time when alien alien and
Aliens had already been out of course
Predator had already been out you had to
have a realistic looking alien and it
had to be Innovative it it had to it had
to convince you that it was a living
creature this is definitely not a damn
living creature and thing it's just a
[ __ ] corny ass little doll and I
think that blew the movie they asked me
that blue movie that yeah and the whole
movie was knocked down to um you could
not suspend your disbelief you're like
okay they're trolling us
that's just what it came off to me and
like I said it's really a shame because
they did have like some of the special
effects in this that you can see look
look really good yeah and they did like
a lot of really big stunts like big
explain car explosions and [ __ ] like
that like all practical but yeah I'm
really not sure like why that looks so
cheap yeah I mean when the rest of it
looks like you know pretty decent yeah
imagine imagine in Aliens when they go
to uh Hadley's hope all right and they
find the the xenomorph facehuggers in
those in those uh jars and imagine if
they just looked like [ __ ]
imagine if they just sucked yeah you'd
be like man [ __ ] this movie you know
well that's what that that's what this
did you're like no
they remind me I remember they had this
toy and I was getting off Stretch
Armstrong this guy you could stretch him
out and he had a villain that went with
him he looked like a little uh Creature
from the Black Lagoon he's green but he
could do the same thing yeah I had I had
that one it looked like that look at
this man I got the damn microphone
[Music]
I didn't do that it's in my face so look
it's in my face it's in my face
we were adjusting it earlier because
when we did the live stream last night
like somebody was talking about how Tom
was like too quiet yeah so then we were
you were like pulling it all around yeah
no
I I find that really hard to believe
because you're always yelling but it's
like yeah people complaining about it
man
[ __ ] shut up
but uh no I think that's the problem
with the movie I think the whole movie I
think the problem the whole movie stems
around because it was it was doing good
until I saw that and I was like
that shouldn't be in this movie I was
like watching uh another review of this
and somebody made and I'm not sure if
this is a joke because I don't like
remember but somebody said it looked
like the same alien that was from like
the opening credits of the X-Files and I
was like I haven't seen the opening
credits for the X-Files in a long time
so it might very well be the same one
maybe they just had like a stock prop
that they used that was like laying
around because it was kind of like the
LA I don't know it's you know what I
mean I don't know but it does seem like
that's really the main thing that I had
just that that alien looking bad I
didn't love Kirstie Alley in it and I
know that that's I mean that I don't
know if that's a controversial statement
but I have seen like some reviews so
like some reviews really really hated
her in it and some reviews really really
liked her in it I didn't see a problem
she I don't know what it was about her
she came across
um one it's it was it got to be like um
a drinking game where it was just kind
of because she's smoking in every single
scene and I guess that was like part of
her character but it's just like after a
while it got kind of like comical
I didn't like she just came across a
little bit to
cynical and a little bit too like snarky
and a little bit I don't know I just
wasn't feeling it uh I didn't hate her
in it but I kind of wish that someone
else had been in that role but it wasn't
like a huge deal it didn't like ruin the
movie for me or anything like that and
to be honest I think I had forgotten too
like what a big uh again it's kind of
like an All-Star cast man like you had
you know Christopher Reeve obviously
like most famously was in this this was
the last movie that he was in before his
horse riding accident like you know
before he uh you know before he had
injuries yeah that was like that sucks
so shitty dude died thinking stem cells
were gonna save him back in those days
that's what I mean it's like it's like
just really stopping everybody was
[ __ ] up about it I mean that was
Superman yeah
and I saw when that accident happened
him flying off the back of that horse
hitting that fence man they played that
over and over again having a horse
background I knew exactly what happened
that wasn't on him that horse
just refused at the jump and [ __ ] he
went over the top in the middle of the
show
his head hit that damn fence and broke
his neck never walked again yeah that's
[ __ ] up yeah and like I said this was
the last movie because I think this
movie came out the same year because I
think the accident was in 1995 like in
May or something like that and um yeah
and this came out like right around that
time or maybe a little bit before a
little bit after I think he's paralyzed
from the neck down I remember yeah
wasn't he yeah I think he was
quadriplegic which is yeah that's that's
[ __ ] tough but yeah so so actually I
really liked him in this
um you know he's
he plays like the town doctor and he's
kind of like this is kind of like an
ensemble cast but he's kind of like the
main character I feel like
um you know because he's the one that
interacts with the kids the most and
he's uh you know the one that's kind of
like in everybody's business because
he's the doctor
um so I don't know okay so I think most
people know but this was actually based
on a 1957 novel by John Windham who is
the same guy who also wrote Dave the
Triffids he was a um like British author
um I read the book but it was so long
ago that I don't really remember like
how similar it was to the movie but they
made a you know black and white version
of this like in 1960 which is actually
pretty good it's not like real scary or
anything it's just kind of very Twilight
Zone episode which you know nothing
wrong with that but the thing about it
and one of the reasons they said they
wanted to remake it like in the 90s was
that they said you know one of the
biggest plot points in the movie
revolves around all of the you know all
of the people in this town essentially
like blacking out and then like when
they wake up however many hours later or
like all the women are pregnant and they
said back in 1960 you couldn't even say
the word pregnant in a movie so it's
like they couldn't even Explore that
um aspect of the plot like all these
women being pregnant them like
considering getting abortions and stuff
like that but they could talk about that
in the 90s so they're like we can at
least delve further into that aspect of
the plot whereas they couldn't even do
that in the 60s I didn't say pregnant in
the 60s no I don't even remember like
the first movie I I feel like that's
something but if you say pregnant in the
sick because because it would make
people think about wombs and vaginas I
guess I don't know you could show a
toilet in there do you remember like
when psycho came out in 1960 everybody
kind of like lost their [ __ ] because it
showed like a toilet like in a bathroom
like in the shower scene you know what I
mean which like it's like it's a it's a
ridiculous people are [ __ ] crazy back
then it's ridiculous and like I said
like everybody knows how pregnant they
works you know what I mean so it's like
why why and you talk about animals
getting pregnant and no that's just
crazy yeah so they had to have like all
these euphemisms yeah so it's like the
fact that they couldn't I mean you know
they couldn't even say the word pregnant
they couldn't say that we're pregnant
but they could use a euphemism for it
right
it's like I don't understand that I
don't understand it either I don't
understand it either but I'm just saying
that it's like so a very large aspect of
the plot like all of these women being
implanted by essentially like an alien
intelligence
um all at the same time they couldn't
even really like explore that in the
movie I can't even remember because I've
seen the original movie too but it's
been a long time so I don't even
remember like how they explained that
like did they just kind of like talk
around it because in this version in the
1995 version you know they show all the
women waking up and then like you know
them getting told they're pregnant and
then someone being like how the [ __ ] can
I be practical is one of the younger
girls was like a virgin and like one of
the women like her husband was out it
was out of the country and so he thought
she was cheating on him and all this
other kind of stuff and so then like
it's it's just kind of like and then
they kind of show them all being
pregnant and then like they jump ahead
to them all giving birth because they
all give birth at the same time so they
have to like set up this big like
converted Barn so they can all like give
birth in there which I thought was kind
of like funny but yeah so so after that
happens I mean like I said I kind of
feel like most people know the story of
this but like all the kids are born and
then they spend a little bit of time
with them like as they're kind of like
babies or toddlers kinda and obviously
they're all born at the same time they
all look the same and they all come
across like hyper intelligent and then
it kind of like jumps ahead several
years it looks like uh because all the
kids are how old do they look probably
like seven eight nine something like
that yeah nine or ten maybe yeah so they
jump ahead like several years and uh at
that point like it's obvious that
there's something like really weird
about these kids because they're all
kind of like a hive mind and they can
also like read your thoughts and mind
powers and they can like make you do
things you know they can talk you into
[ __ ] and so like if you kill yourself
yeah so like if anybody threatens them
because like the one kid like when she
was a baby the Christopher Reeves wife
like the woman that's in like that plays
his wife
um when the when their daughter whose
name is Mara who comes across like later
as like the leader of the little
children
um she I don't know I don't exactly know
because usually what happens is like if
anybody threatens the kids or like says
some sideways [ __ ] about the kids then
the kids like their eyes will start to
grow and they're like oh no and they're
like woo like that and then like the
person's like oh I think I'd like to
like you know chop my head off with an
ax or whatever it is but um I don't
think the mom did anything specifically
like the little girl was just in oh you
know what you know what it was I think
she gave her something to eat that she
didn't like like she gave her like some
applesauce or soup or something like
yeah Deb that's what it was she gave her
some soup and then she said oh is the
soup too hot because the kid like threw
it off the thing and then the kid like
was like whoa like looked at her and
like she would like stick your arm in
like the boiling yeah she boiled her own
hands she boiled her own hand
um so yeah I had forgotten about that
like where the kid got mad about the
suit because she was like still a baby
at that point yeah they they take over
the town basically and they got the
people basically as their servants
they're aliens yeah aliens are human
bodies I mean that's what I mean that's
the um the book the original book is
called the midwich Cuckoos which like I
said you know a cuckoo bird like as you
know comes and lays its eggs in other
birds nests like other species and then
like it's born and kicks out the other
birds things same kind of that's the
same thing as uh vivarium you know what
I mean that was kind of the same
iconography they were using in that so
it's it's that same type of thing and
now there's one kid whose name is David
and his mom is played by uh Linda
Kozlowski who was in Crocodile Dundee I
think she was in all the Crocodile
Dundee movies that's where I recognized
her from and uh so her son he's like the
only one that kind of seems halfway
normal or has like human characteristics
and they explain that it's because when
all the when all the children of the
Damned that's actually what the sequel
was called Children of the Damned but
when all the children were born like one
of them that um was birthed by the girl
that was a virgin
that one died and that was the one that
was supposed to be paired off with David
because that's another weird thing is
that all the kids have a counterpart you
know what I mean say I'll walk around in
like Little Couples and I guess the
implication they don't say this but I
guess the implication is that they can't
be a complete being unless there's both
of them you know what I mean so because
David didn't have his counterpart
because that baby died then he is not
like in the hive mind as much as the
other ones because he's still able to
feel empathy or he's still able to like
understand
um you know when his mom like explains
stuff to him and he kind of feels bad
about things whereas the other kids are
just like straight sociopaths you know
what I'm saying so I thought that was
kind of like an interesting Dynamic too
and that's because he was the only one
that was
a little bit more like a regular kid uh
they didn't really want to wipe out him
at the end you know what I mean because
he had the potential to be normal
although they left the end
ambiguous as to whether you know after
he got saved because you know spoiler
alert Christopher Reed blows up all the
other kids
colonies of them all over the Earth yeah
yeah so it wouldn't really have made a
difference they were taking over the
Earth
just very very slowly it seemed like
you'd do it well yeah it seemed like
they were almost kind of like
experimenting because didn't they say
because at some point like Kirsty alley
she comes into town like after the weird
anomaly happens with everybody falling
asleep and then waking up and all the
women being pregnant like she comes
there as she works for she's like a
doctor but she's like an epidemiologist
so she's like you know working for the
feds or like National Institutes of
Health or whatever and so she comes
there and they you find out later on
that this same thing has happened in
other places and it always happens in
like these really small isolated towns
so it's almost like the aliens are like
doing test runs and like seeing how
shit's gonna work out colonization right
that's like what they're doing you can't
do that in a major city because they'd
have they'd have the city would have the
organization and the organizational
faculties to kill the kids yeah do it in
a little town you can take over that
little town
once they're adults they move out to the
rest of the population they got mental
dominance over people yeah
this is how you would do it if you were
an invasive species trying to invade
Earth
the first thing you'd have to do is
you'd need a human body because you have
you have to have the biology necessary
in order to integrate in with the
ecosystem
so if you're an alien you're probably
not gonna be able to breathe the
atmosphere you're not going to be able
to do a bunch of stuff tip of Steel
bodies and that's what they did they
kind of like
I guess they took their DNA and maybe
their souls per se I don't know you know
a [ __ ] quantum physics and they
impregnate themselves into into the
females and come out with a human body
so they're fully adapt it's fully
adapted to living on the planet but then
they're a hive mind
with that type of mental powers that
that they're shown having here that
easily take over the planet
the only thing that was wrong with them
that I would say was not a good strategy
is that they all have the same hair
color
yeah and it's a very weird like unusual
words they were it was white white and
that would be a giveaway it'd be better
if they were camouflaged where you
couldn't tell them from a normal human
maybe when they got older they'd start
like dying there so they could like
right because maybe that was like the
one aspect of the that they couldn't
control because of like some kind of
genetic anomaly or they just spread out
and get into politics and take over the
governments that's that's what they
would do and then they'd be in charge of
everything then they'd kill off the
population and replace everybody with
themselves
they knew what everybody was thinking
that's why it was so difficult for you
know them to because everybody just got
it was almost kind of like that Twilight
Zone episode with the kid that could
like wish people into the cornfield and
like kind of do what you they were like
that uh and they were super powerful and
they could all they had to do was know
it's like hey you're thinking about
[ __ ] us over and then it's like hey
put that shotgun in your mouth and like
blow your witches what happens to Mark
Hamill is in this by the way like
playing a priest it's not a huge role
but he's in it and uh that's what they
make him do because he actually like
goes Rogue and he's like I'm gonna shoot
these little [ __ ] I mean
understandably but they make him shoot
his own head up it makes sense why they
got Carpenter to do this because the
thing is the same situation yeah an
invasive species take and the thing
could have taken over the planet that
was it if the thing got out that's a
wrap you couldn't fight that that's why
I said that's I always say that's the
scariest monster like if that was real
we would we would be hoes this would be
similar if it was done the way you
probably couldn't stop that no the
Xenomorphs from Aliens you can stop that
you could fight those because those
couldn't hide and you could you could
deal with those with Force
you clearly couldn't use Force against
these things because you'd have to find
them and they would blend in yeah and
they would be human until they told you
until they weren't until they weren't
here
the thing could be whatever it wanted so
that was even worse and it could spread
fast we'd have to kill off the human
population and just absorb them you know
which that that's even worse yeah
um kind of like the biological version
of the Borg from Star Trek yeah they
were very borg-like and then this is
very I mean I kind of feel like you know
there was a lot of this kind of stuff
going on in sci-fi like in the 50s where
you had a story like this you also had
like Invasion of the Body Snatchers
um you know that kind of stuff which was
actually like a novel I think when did
the novel come in I think Jack Finney
wrote it and I think that came out in
the 50s too but it was just very much
kind of like an individual versus
Collective type of thing that was like
very much in the air in the 50s so a lot
of sci-fi was based around that idea and
it's very much this is kind of like
Invasion of the Body except you know
it's not stealing bodies
yeah it's like they're they look like
people but they are and they're born of
of people but they're obviously not
because there's one scene toward the end
where the little girl uh Mara
she's kind of like trying to use all of
her like mental powers and you for a
second like when her eyes like start
glowing red and everything you see like
the alien underneath like what she
really looks like like beneath and it's
not it's not like a great effect but
it's weird because the way they did it I
saw like a clip of Greg nicotero like
talking about it and they actually built
like an alien head that like moved
around and all this other stuff and I
guess that they shot it like moving the
same way as the little girl's face and
then they superimposed it over and like
did a negative so it like looked red it
looks kind of cool but I mean it looks
very 90s so it's like a little bit
cheesy now the little baby alien that
they had in the jar
what was that supposed to represent was
that like a new queen that was no that
was the baby that had died okay that
Kirsty alley stole because remember when
all the babies were being born at the
beginning okay like Kirsty alley like
grabbed the the one virgin girl's baby
and said oh it's stillborn and then she
ran out and stuck it in her truck okay
so it was a stillborn baby so it was a
stillborn baby so she didn't want
anybody to see it she was like really
sneaky so she took it back to the lab
and I guess they'd been experimenting on
it all this time but that's what that
was if they were gonna show that that
stillborn baby it shouldn't have looked
anything like what they showed it
shouldn't looked like that I mean they
could have like shot it if they could
have shot it in the dark they could have
shot it from the back they could have I
mean even if they if they were forced to
use that special effect there's ways
they could have lit it or something like
that would have would have looked better
it would have made it look like a curled
up baby grasshopper or something you
know what I mean something just not
human at all like something that was
turned into a human shape eventually but
costing a human and a yeah
see those like big old big old water
bugs sometimes floating into damn jars
and formaldehyde yeah in school
something like that that's that's what
it should have looked like I just got a
damn water bug put it in there that's
the thing though but it's like here's
what okay but here's what I didn't get
unless I totally missed this I assumed
and I I just said this like you know
very authoritatively and I could be
totally wrong I thought that that alien
baby in the jar like I said was the baby
that had died that Kirstie Alley stole
but the thing about it was that if the
babies all looked like that because she
said it was dead now I don't know if
they are implying that the baby wasn't
dead that she took it it was still alive
so like oh sorry your baby's dead and
then she took it and then she kept it
alive for a little while until it
started looking like an alien but see
there was like tons and tons of other
doctors and people and [ __ ] like that
there when all the other babies were
born you notice that gesture yeah and
they didn't look like that like they
presumably looked normal because and
well no they did look normal because
they showed them putting the babies on
like and they looked like normal human
babies right so I so maybe I just
figured this out like right this second
because I did think that Kirsty alley
that's not her like that's not our
character's name obviously but it's
Kirsty alley um I did think that Kirstie
Alley was being like super Shifty like
the way she pulled it out the girl's
badge and she's like oh I'm sorry it's
still born and I was like that [ __ ]
lying that baby's not dead so and then
she like Runs Out to the fence like
stuffs it in the car and I was just kind
of like did she lie about it being dead
but then like later on when they you
know at the very end you see that the
crappy looking alien baby in the jar and
I was like oh maybe it was dead but now
that I'm thinking about it I'm like well
it must have been alive it must have
been alive and she must have kept it
alive for some time and when it died and
then transformed into today or as it
grew because like I said it had been a
long time like she took the babies and
then like back in midwich in the town it
had been what like nine or ten years
because the kids were grown unless they
grew super fast but nobody said anything
about it I think it was a [ __ ] up maybe
but it was they didn't think about they
didn't think it through if it was born
like all the rest of him and that was
born stillborn well maybe it was
stillborn it was [ __ ] up because it
still looked like an alien instead of a
human it was a mistake it was a mistake
okay maybe that's okay it was all right
fair enough it's the only the only way
that could have been does it but if that
was a baby that was a big ass baby that
it will it was still born and it didn't
work whatever it was and you could see
it it didn't take you could see that it
was enhanced you could see that it was
an alien all right that actually that
makes more sense only now that you
mentioned yeah it's probably the only
thing that it could have been okay plot
hole averted I was kind of worried about
it but it didn't look good enough it
didn't like I said if you were gonna
show it yeah um you know show like the
Revelation oh my God they're aliens even
though you already knew that it was it
looked better as if it was a damn mass
of tentacles you just make the thing out
of a [ __ ] a real octopus that would
have looked yeah they could have just
like went to a lab and like use like a
like a squid or something yeah and made
it and had that floating in there that
would have looked a lot better although
maybe that maybe then it wouldn't have
been as obvious that it was supposed to
be the baby like it would have had to be
Humanity with that face that alien face
on it or put human body parts like
little baby arms coming out of it it's
got tentacles the little baby arms we
better come up if I was on that movie we
would have come up with something I
would I'm just curious to know if you
know if nicotera and his team did that
because they usually do like amazing
work and honestly the other effects in
this that you can see I think nicotero
was really disappointed because the the
bit of
um you know the interview with him that
I saw was like we did all these really
cool effects like they're seen toward
the end again spoiler alert where Kirsty
alley they basically make her like
autopsy herself right she like she
sticks the the scalpel like in her
stomach and pulls it up and it's like
it's all implied they don't show it and
I got the sense that they actually did
do the gruesome effects for that but it
all got cut out which is dumb because
this was a universal film and they were
gonna they knew that it was gonna be an
R rating but then it seemed like they
cut out a lot of the like gruesome
special effects because this movie is
like not maybe there's a director's cut
maybe not I mean not that I know of I
was watching a couple like I watched a
review earlier of like somebody that had
got like the Blu-ray yeah and they
didn't mention that there was like a
director's cut on it like I said I don't
think that John Carpenter because this
wasn't like a passion project of his it
was just a contractual thing like he
doesn't hate this movie he's like you
know I he was just kind of like oh well
it didn't work out the way he wanted or
blah blah blah and they cut a lot of it
out
um you know when him and Christopher
Reeve I think they kind of like butted
heads a little bit on the uh on the set
as well even though I think it worked
out later in the end but I think it
didn't come out quite the way he wanted
so he was just like ah [ __ ] it uh
because it wasn't really like his movie
but I don't know I think he's a little
more charitable toward it toward it
nowadays but it does seem like a lot of
it was cut out you know what I mean like
a lot of the gross stuff it's violent in
the sense that you know people have like
die in like horrible ways but a lot of
it is not shown or it's just like
implied so it seemed like a lot lot of
it was trimmed out like you know that it
that it was like a lot grosser or more
graphic and like it got kind of you know
it got kind of like cut up a little bit
I just got that sense from it and that's
just from listening to Greg nicotero
talk about it and listening to the woman
that played Christopher Reeves wife in
it you know she's like when we saw the
movie she's like you know where is it
like because a lot of it got cut out so
I guess a lot of it did get cut out I'm
not really sure why it sucks it was
probably great yeah I mean like yeah
it's got to be out there maybe they'll
re-release it or something with with the
[ __ ] that they cut out somebody's got to
have the the the footage yeah you would
think let's try out there you would
think I'm sure some studio had brought
has it because like I said you know
there's one scene where you know you
have like uh much like in Frankenstein
you have like all the torch wielding
villagers that come to like we're gonna
[ __ ] up those kids those goddamn kids
and they all have torches and stuff
which is actually like kind of funny but
like the main lady that has the torch
and then you know of course the kids are
standing there and make her set her own
ass on fire and then like they show her
or burned up corpse like at the end and
that looks fantastic that looks like
really grotesque and they did a really
good job it looks really realistic and
so I kind of feel like I would have
liked to have seen more of that I would
have liked this to be like more gruesome
because like I said a lot of people holy
[ __ ] that one scene toward the end where
like the cops come there and then the
kids like make all the cops turn on each
other and there's like a huge this is
huge [ __ ] where all these cops
are like hitting each other's cars the
car is blowing up they're [ __ ]
blowing each other away and all this
other kind of stuff and I just kind of
feel like you know they could have they
should have done more of that I feel
like I've got a feeling that this movie
might grow on you if you've watched it a
couple times yeah I think so too like I
think so too I've seen it a couple times
this is probably the third time I've
seen it although I haven't seen it last
time I saw it was like a really long
time this is the first time I've seen it
I saw little bits of it over the years
and it never really caught my never it
never really could keep my attention I
was probably doing other things I was
thinking I was in the Army when this
came out what year did this come out 95
yeah no I've been I've been out of
so
but uh I remember seeing bits of it
parts of it I recognized but I'd never
seen it
it I'd never seen it completely yeah
even watching it this time I had to step
out a couple minutes and get back in
because I had [ __ ] I had to do
downstairs but
it's I'd like to see it again it's not
it's it's a good movie I'm gonna say I'm
gonna I want to say it's not a bad movie
but that's actually not doing it justice
it's a good movie it's worth watching
it's a good movie it's
um it's not perfect but no movie really
is it's
I want to see it again it reminded it
was reminded me of a cross between the
The Andromeda Strain and um
and uh
body Invasion of the Body Snatchers and
a little bit like the thing
kinda but mostly Invasion of the Body
Snatchers but it has a it kind of felt
like a disaster flick in the beginning
of it they're finding all these sleeping
people everywhere and they're finding
the boundaries of it that it's not gas
it must be some kind of an energy field
that's doing this
um I thought that was [ __ ]
interesting I really liked that build up
I think actually I think the build up is
better than the reveal because you
already know it's aliens you already
kind of know what's gonna so like the
build up and the Mystery around that I
think is like the best part still not
the mystery of what what the hell is
happening and that part kind of reminded
me of The Andromeda Strain yeah where
you're not really sure exactly what's
happening you know it has something to
do with aliens but everyone's just
laying around and like this and then
suddenly everybody gets up and they're
fine well except for that one guy that
fell on the grill and got burned up then
it starts becoming kind of like uh
starts becoming a little bit like
Invasion of the Body Snatchers and kind
of like a plague movie in a way and then
it's it's an alien invasion movie you
know it's pretty good it's pretty good I
want to see it again they're invading
our wombs yeah damn it
but yeah I think it could grow on me
yeah the movie could grow on like I said
it's not I mean it's not one of
Carpenter's best obviously um but you
know but I I think it's better than some
of his other movies that came out in the
90s I'm gonna say that I do wish it was
creepier I wish that I didn't get the
sense that a lot of it was cut out
particularly I feel like there was a lot
of Gore and stuff like that that was cut
out and I kind of wish that they had put
that back in I wish they had shot a
little bit more of it at night so it was
a bit creepier right um I and I will say
too like I thought the kid actors were
fine
um some of them were better than others
I think the kids were creepier when they
were babies though
and like once they got a little bit
older and started talking I don't think
they were quite as creepy some of those
wigs the haircuts of those wigs I don't
think were any good like that one girl's
haircut was kind of weird looking just
but you know it was the time the weird
thing about that is I don't think those
were wigs I think that they actually did
all their hair like that because they
said I was watching I was watching like
a review about it earlier and they said
the um that the the people like the crew
that were dude did all the kids hair
like and they bleached it and everything
they said they spent all this time like
bleaching all these kids hair and
styling it like to make it look a little
bit weird and a little bit alien and
stuff and then they said and then all
the reviews came out of like complain
about how shitty the wigs were there's
like there weren't wigs that's your hair
you know what I mean I don't know if
that's true or not but that's what I've
heard I didn't think the cuts were uh
they did look like wigs though yeah I
have to say the the cuts on some of the
girls didn't look that good yeah it
would have been better if they were just
straight parted in the middle and it
would look a lot cooler yeah yeah I'm
not really sure why that because it
looked a little bit like that Dorothy
Hamill thing that was going on like in
the 70s that weird like cup like put
those pudding cups
or whatever kind of sleek and
sophisticated just straight hair parted
in the middle and the boys just should
have had the damn [ __ ] side comb
[ __ ] 1950s looking real kind of
military yeah military officer what do
they call it like a high and tight or
something come like a little bit like a
high entire and it would have been like
the kids demanded those you know what I
mean yeah like we all had to have this
they all had to have the same haircut
and it's the girl's all the same the
boys all the same man yeah I think it
would have looked better yeah like with
the girls just kind of like straight
like this hair yeah because it would
look like no fuss right you know what I
mean and it wouldn't like draw attention
to it and if their hair was born
perfectly straight anyway you didn't
have to do anything to it so cut the
ends yeah and it was [ __ ] Platinum
you know white yeah albino colored you
know and that that's the way it came and
that's how they rolled and that you
weren't messing with her hair and the
boys were all ready for combat and then
that would have made a lot more sense to
me that they were an alien unit
basically an alien invasion unit
yeah yeah because they would go around
like in pairs like in Little like they
were a little military like a little
military unit they always went
everywhere together you know what I mean
so yeah a lot more sense that's a good
idea actually this could be this could
be remade yeah um you could make this
actually like pretty creepy because
creepy kids are always creepy but but
you'd really need like you said you
really need some creepy ass children and
you could put it in a modern day yeah
internet and cell phones and everything
and it makes sense because they just
dominate you through a damn cell phone
or the internet
yeah that's another thing they could
actually like make videos and like get
like everybody that watched it that
could get him to do like all kind of
[ __ ] right and today we're gonna and it
would be much faster Take Over Control
and governments and controlling
corporations and [ __ ] like that and uh
to expanding their power that way taking
over you know [ __ ] uh Elon Musk and
all the other oligarchs and they're
under their control you know what I mean
and that would be a lot it could be like
something on a Black Mirror
and then you have people trying to
resist that yeah you hear that you guys
that's yeah it would be a good idea I
would do Villages yeah and they would
grow to adulthood or early
or early adulthood and there because
actually they could they had the power
as soon as they're teenagers they'd be
able to [ __ ] take over because they
were damn near taking over when they're
about 10. Yeah well yeah because like I
said they were smarter and they could
read all your thoughts yeah the old way
although I will say the only way to
defeat them and this was the same as the
original movie is that Christopher Reeve
figured out that if he thought of
something that was like all-encompassing
like an ocean or like a brick wall or
something like that it was much harder
for them to like penetrate so you'd have
to like learn how to like block them
from reading your thoughts you can make
a good story because then you'd have
resistance units of humans that learned
to resist them Walling off their
thoughts playing cards in their heads
anything to kind of throw them off
and uh assassinating them not make a
great movie that'd make a great series
it would actually and I was watching
another review earlier but they said
that maybe that this would probably have
been a better series because like in the
vein of Stephen King because because
it's such an ensemble and it's set in
one town even though it's a small town
it's like it would have been cool if
you'd have been able to spend more time
with the people in the town and also you
could follow it through because like I
said you know you have the thing at the
beginning where everybody falls asleep
and they get pregnant then it kind of
jumps ahead to the the women giving
birth and then it's like there's kind of
a short period of time where the where
they're like babies or Toddlers and then
it jumps ahead like nine years or
whatever it is when the kids are like
kind of you know part way grown so it
would be cool if you could just kind of
like follow [ __ ] because I found myself
thinking like once they jumped ahead
like to the kids being older I was like
well what was going on all that time
that we didn't see you know what I mean
well what you could do is you can make
this make this like a series of one of
the streaming services
and um
it would be kind of like a the series V
remember the old 80s yes V where a bunch
of lizard people in skin suits subtly
kind of in public take over the planet
but yeah they seemed friendly at first
they take over all the governments and
the corporate you do it like that but
it's Village of the Damned
and it starts with their kids and the
village thing and then eventually
they're growing older and then they're
taken over and they're linking up all
the [ __ ] colonies all over the planet
or linking up with each other you got
scientists that understand yeah we've
been [ __ ] impregnated with alien DNA
and they're like you you could it would
be badass I mean [ __ ] you could do I
mean that's three seasons right there
yeah and then you could have [ __ ] where
certain militaries are trying to respond
and part of the military is trying to
kill the Alien Children and then the
other part of the militaries are trying
to defend them because they're all
controlled they're all controls there's
all kinds of cool [ __ ] you could do you
wouldn't be able to trust people
yeah see it's gonna be a great idea like
I said this definitely needs because the
story behind it is it's such a great
premise yeah
um but it really needs like a lot more
room to expand yeah like maybe just than
one movie and then you could have some
of the alien kids in the hive mind some
of them are Rebels and don't really
agree with what's happening like like
you said in this story yeah some of them
were like you know we really shouldn't
be taking over this way that type of
[ __ ] yeah have some like I said just
like in this one like if you know
because obviously Something's Gonna go
wrong somewhere so if their partner dies
like in childbirth then that then
they'll be like kind of like not as
integrated as the other aliens and
they'll be more sympathetic to the
humans yes there's more than one faction
of aliens right that'd be cool too
because if you didn't have some of those
aliens helping the humans the humans
yeah we'd be [ __ ] so you need it you
need a way to to where some of the
aliens are supporting the human
endeavors for for uh to stay independent
or whatever but no I can make a great
series especially if I had some other
people writing with us we could come up
with some crazy [ __ ] be good yeah like I
said and you could use you know John
windham's novel and like kind of you
know make nods to the movies but call it
planet of the Damned
planet of the Damned that's what I'd
call that [ __ ]
you'd have a Mega Man thrown in there
and everything
like I said you could have like the
first season could just be about you
know everybody passing out and the
pregnancies you could follow the
pregnancies you could do a whole season
just about that and then you could have
like the babies born at the end of the
first season and then the second one you
have the kids kind of like getting like
being Toddlers and getting older and
have them like infiltrating like just
this town and then like as the series
went on like it gets bigger and bigger
and like starts kind of like
exacerbating metastasizing cross between
uh
cross between like V
and um The Walking Dead yeah I'd watch
that or you know what's it called uh uh
Planet Z no it was the one where uh what
was that when the zombies were taking
over the [ __ ] planet something to see
World War Z kind of like that Village of
the damn World War Z altogether because
you'd have some of the humans would be
[ __ ] hijacked they'd be fighting you
it'd be good
if you did it right yeah I can picture
it I could picture it yeah I think it
would be good but you know we'll see I'm
sure they'll get around to it one of
these days because it sounds like the
same kind of stuff that people are
making yeah you know that that people
are like uh really into nowadays so I
just do feel I might be able to come up
with something like that not even need
the licensing just to all the [ __ ] an
original thing I call this yeah I mean
as long as you've changed it enough yeah
don't call it villager damned call it
planet of the Damned and change certain
things about it and it's not quite the
same story it's a different it's
happening in a different time it's
different group of people different [ __ ]
happens you know but it's in that same
universe you just kind of don't say that
it's just allude to that that it's in
that same universe the original Village
of the Damned from 1960 I'm pretty sure
it had at least one sequel because I
think the sequel was called Children of
the Damned which I think I've seen that
too but I can't really remember what
happened in it I explained that explains
[ __ ] that uh Iron Maiden song
Children of the Damned yeah yeah that's
probably what they're talking about it
was but it's like I'm not sure what
happened in the sequel because you know
maybe it was about that one kid that
they that they said oh he's kind of like
he seems like he's okay so we're gonna
save him because like I said at the end
of this movie like Christopher Reeve
like puts the brick wall in his mind and
then blows up all the other kids yeah
along with himself which I was like well
did he really have to do that though I
mean he could have just put the bomb
like on the outside of the barn and then
come in and said uh hey you guys like
why don't you just like sit here in this
uh classroom here for a little while and
I'm just gonna pop out to the car and
then Bland like he didn't have to
sacrifice himself I wouldn't imagine
well she's there
she crashed out oh she heard you move in
here just crashed out inside her pile of
toys she just got in her toy pile and
she's like well I guess that's about all
I can say about this huh yeah yeah yeah
all right so yeah like I said if you're
into John Carpenter it's worth watching
it's better than some of his other stuff
but I feel like it got [ __ ] on quite a
bit and it was a horrible Financial
failure
but you know it's definitely worth
watching I mean there was a lot of stuff
that I actually really liked about it I
just kind of wish that it hadn't been
you know it seems like it's got caught
up a little bit which is a shame because
it was probably like some good effects
working [ __ ] like that but yeah that'll
do it for this movie retrospective we'll
see you guys again on the next one bye